Hey Thoughty2 here.
In 1796 Edward Jenner, a local doctor in Gloucestershire,
England, became obsessed with milkmaids.
He started observing them, he said it was
for medical research but we’ve all heard
that one before.
But after a while he started to notice something
peculiar, all the milkmaids were immune to
smallpox, a highly virulent and common, killer
disease at the time.
He suspected this was because milkmaids often
contracted the relatively mild disease of
cowpox first, which somehow made them immune
to smallpox.
Jenner carried out a famous experiment on
an eight-year-old boy and purposely injected
him with a small amount of the cowpox virus.
As Jenner had hypothesized, the boy was now
immune to smallpox.
He was so confident that he even carried out
the experiment on his 11-month-old son.
Two years later Jenner published his research,
coining the word “vaccine” from the Latin
“vacca”, meaning cow.
Of course, because the Catholic Church were,
as usual, intimidated by Jenner’s progressive
thinking, they launched a smear campaign to
ridicule him and his research.
Luckily for millions and millions of lives,
pragmatism eventually prevailed and in 1803
Jenner was awarded government funding as the
usage of vaccines became widespread throughout
Europe and the US.
All was going well for a couple of hundred
years and then in 1998 a former British doctor
and medical researcher called Andrew Wakefield
published a research paper claiming that there
is a strong link between vaccinations and
the onset of Autism.
Six years passed by and his research had led
to rumours all around the world that vaccines
cause Autism.
To make matters worse numerous Hollywood celebrities,
got caught up in it all and publically spoke
out, about how they believe vaccines are linked
to Autism.
And as we all know, celebrities are the fountain
of all knowledge.
Yes, I did just insult myself.
But since Wakefield’s claims were getting
a lot of media attention around the world,
other scientific researchers and investigative
journalists started to test Wakefield’s
claims and dig a little deeper.
It turned out that all of Wakefield’s research
was entirely unsubstantiated, and a lot of
it had been entirely falsified.
And then a journalist for the Sunday Times
discovered that Wakefield had undisclosed
financial conflicts of interest, naughty naughty.
An investigation ensued against Wakefield,
he had also heavily mistreated Autistic children
during his experiments.
Eventually he was completely discredited and
barred from practicing medicine in the UK
ever again.
Of course the news of all this didn’t gain
a speck of media attention, unlike the story
the vaccines do cause Autism, so the world
was left in the dark, still believing in his
fake research.
So to put it simply, this whole vaccine-autism
rumour that spread like wildfire, and still
perpetuates today, was born out of lies and
fake research.
So then, it’s pretty clear where I’m going
with this video, but let’s dig a little
deeper.
Because despite all this happening in 2004,
a recent poll revealed that 18% of Americans
still believe Vaccines cause Autism, including
their president.
So how does a vaccine work anyway?
Well a vaccine is basically an expansion pack
for our immune system.
When harmful microbes enter our body our immune
system kicks into action and releases anti
bodies, little battleships that hunt down
the invading virus or bacteria and exterminate
it.
But that’s not all your body does, it also
records a memory of the configuration of that
specific pathogen, and the best way to denature
it.
Because every pathogen is different, a different
approach is needed, in order for our immune
system to deal with each and every one.
A vaccine contains either a very small and
safe amount of the actual pathogen which it’s
intended to protect you from or a pathogen
which is already dead.
Once the inactive pathogen has been injected
into our body, an immune system response is
trigged and it learns everything about the
pathogen and remembers it, so if it ever comes
along again, in greater numbers, our immune
system is well-prepared.
Countless studies have shown that this is
a perfectly safe way to immunize your body
against future infections.
There has been literally no scientific evidence
found suggesting that vaccines are in any
way unsafe.
Some complain of feeling ill after a vaccine,
but unless by coincidence, they’re not actually
sick, it’s just because there are side-effects
to our immune system being triggered, and
these side-effects happen to be the same symptoms
as flu, such as excessive sweating, muscle
cramps, headaches etc.
So if it’s not the active ingredient in
the vaccine, the inactive pathogen, that’s
allegedly causing autism, then what is it?
Well a vaccine does contain a small number
of ancillary ingredients.
These additions are simply there to stimulate
your immune system and help it to do its job,
against the newly introduced pathogen.
So could these strange chemicals cause us
harm?
Very unlikely, all the commonly used vaccine
ingredients are natural and can already be
found in the human body, such as aluminum
and gelatine.
The most controversial vaccine ingredient
has been an antiseptic and preservative called
Thiomersal, which was the main ingredient
that people believed was responsible for causing
autism.
Although no scientific evidence could ever
be found that supported these claims.
However due to public concern Thiomersal was
immediately removed from all vaccines across
the whole of the Europe and America.
So that’s no longer a concern.
So have any studies been carried out to test
the link between vaccines and autism?
Well yes, quite a few actually, over 50, independent,
evidence-based studies have been conducted,
specifically investigating the supposed link
between Autism and Vaccines and all of them
concluded that there was no evidence linking
the two.
Furthermore, some studies have found that
having a large amount of vaccines in a short
space of time, as an infant, has no negative
side-effects.
A growing number of people are refusing to
vaccinate their children, but doing this doesn’t
just affect them It’s also incredibly dangerous
for the rest of humanity, because it increases
the chances of pathogens multiplying between
hosts, mutating and becoming a global pandemic.
So yeah, just think about that next time you
base your entire scientific consensus from
an infographic you saw on Facebook.
It’s easy to see why some people are so
eager to make the connection.
Autism is typically identified in children
between the ages of 2 and 3, however symptoms
can appear between the ages of 1 to 2.
Although it differs from country to country,
these crucial years are typically when children
are given the majority of their major vaccines,
such as measles, mumps and rubella.
So the timeframes line up perfectly to shove
the blame onto vaccines.
When backed up by a “scientific study”,
albeit falsified, it’s easy to see how this
rumour quickly grew into something quite large.
But if you still adamantly believe the tweets
of celebrities, a post your friend shared
on Facebook and the results of a singular
study that has been proven entirely untrustworthy,
over mountains of evidence brought forward
by people who have dedicated their entire
lives to the study of medicine and vaccines,
then there’s little else I can do to change
your mind.
If you really do need further clarification,
then I can only suggest you visit howdovaccinescauseautism.com.
It truly
was an eye-opener for me.
Thanks for watching.